2021's "Mortal Kombat" may be a faithful video
game movie, but it still makes some major
changes to the games' classic kombatants.
Here are all the major differences between
the characters in the games and the movie.
Sub-Zero has become a standard-bearer of the
"Mortal Kombat" series, to the point that
the phrase "Mortal Kombat" likely conjures
his enigmatically masked face in many fans'
minds.
He's appeared as a playable fighter in every
single new "Mortal Kombat" game since the
very first one arrived in arcades in 1992.
So it makes sense that Sub-Zero freeze-blasts
his way on to the silver screen as the 2021
movie's primary villain.
But there's a little detail about this cinematic
Sub-Zero most viewers aren't going to pick
up on, which reveals him to be a different
Sub-Zero than the one featured in the modern
slate of "Mortal Kombat" games.
"Bi-Han!"
Sub-Zero begins the movie under his given
name, Bi-Han.
But Bi-Han is not the Sub-Zero most "Mortal
Kombat" players know and love, unless their
frame of reference is firmly rooted in the
early '90s.
Indeed, Bi-Han is the original Sub-Zero, featured
in the very first "Mortal Kombat" game.
But in that inaugural game, Scorpion kills
Bi-Han.
In subsequent entries, his younger brother,
Kuai Liang, takes up the Sub-Zero mantle.
It is Kuai Liang, rather than Bi-Han, who
appears as Sub-Zero in pretty much every game
since 1993's "Mortal Kombat II."
The exception to this occurs in the 2011 "Mortal
Kombat" game, in which both versions of the
character are featured.
Scorpion's origins are humble: His first design
is exactly the same as Sub-Zero's, save for
his yellow color scheme.
Since those early days, however, Scorpion
has gone on to become one of the most iconic
"Mortal Kombat" characters around, second
only to his icy counterpart.
He goes by his birth name, Hanzo Hasashi,
for most of the 2021 movie, and isn't featured
as heavily as many fans might have been expecting.
In fact, he dies in the prologue, and doesn't
reappear until he gets his revenge on Sub-Zero
in the final minutes of the film.
"Get over here!"
There are two key differences between Scorpion
in the new "Mortal Kombat" movie and Scorpion
in the "Mortal Kombat" games.
In the first game, as in the movie, Scorpion
is driven to hunt down Sub-Zero after the
cryomancer kills his family ... or so he believes.
According to the games' lore, it is actually
Netherrealm demon Quan Chi who commits the
atrocious killing — but Scorpion doesn't
learn this until multiple entries later.
Related to this point is the second key difference
between the cinematic Scorpion and his game-bound
counterpart.
The movie introduces a major new twist to
his origin: A surviving heir.
In 2021's "Mortal Kombat," Hanzo's youngest
daughter manages to survive the massacre,
and goes on to continue a bloodline that eventually
results in the birth of Cole.
Aside from newbie Cole and his family, Sonya
Blade is the only classic "Mortal Kombat"
character to get a brand new character arc
in the 2021 film.
This movie brings a new facet to the complex
lore of "Mortal Kombat:" The dragon mark.
The dragon mark is a small brand in the shape
of the "Mortal Kombat" logo, and is what designates
fighters as kombatants and gives them their
arcana-based powers.
Cole is born with his dragon mark, but many
of the movie's fighters earn theirs in the
only other way a person might hope to do so:
They kill someone who already has the mark.
When we meet Sonya early on, she is unmarked.
Any "Mortal Kombat" fan could tell you that
it's not a group of Earthrealm protectors
without Sonya Blade, so it's not a surprise
that this state of affairs doesn't last.
This is the core of Sonya's story in "Mortal
Kombat:" Her journey ends when she takes the
dragon mark from Kano by killing him with
a pretty gnarly stab through the head.
He's a suitable victim for Sonya, given their
long-running rivalry in the "Mortal Kombat"
games and comics.
Kano, as depicted in the 2021 movie, is a
foul-mouthed mercenary who feels very much
in keeping with the spirit of the game character
... with one notable exception.
The vast majority of the "Mortal Kombat" games'
storytelling positions Kano as the nemesis
of Sonya Blade and Jax.
So it's a bit of a twist to see him helping
Liu Kang train Cole in the 2021 film.
Or is it?
We hate to ruin the fun and suspense, but
any "Mortal Kombat" fan worth their salt can
tell you that Kano is the master of betrayal.
Without completely giving away the details
of the movie, let's just say that "Mortal
Kombat" delivers on Kano and Sonya Blade's
rivalry, and makes Kano the lovable scumbag
he truly is.
"You f---in' beauty."
Another interesting difference between Kano
of the movie and Kano of the games lies in
his status within the Black Dragon clan: In
the current timeline of the games, Kano is
the group's leader, but in the new film, he
is merely a member.
The only other thing missing is his cybernetic
heart, which allows him to shoot out blasts
from his chest to annihilate his foes.
Hopefully, we'll be seeing a little of that
action in subsequent "Mortal Kombat" movies.
Of all the main characters featured in 2021's
"Mortal Kombat," Jax is the only fighter who
isn't part of the first game's roster.
Introduced in "Mortal Kombat II," special
forces agent Jax Briggs instantly immortalized
himself, and has appeared as a playable character
in almost every "Mortal Kombat" game since.
Unless you haven't touched the series since
his introduction in "MK II," you probably
noticed something off about Jax at the start
of the movie ... or, to be specific, two things.
That's right: In the movie, Jax has normal
human arms!
Ever since "Mortal Kombat III," Jax has been
known best for his titanium, cybernetic arms,
which allow him to go toe-to-toe with dark
sorcerers and outright gods.
This might seem like a shocking departure
few fans would be able to embrace, let alone
get excited about, but consider this: Now
we get to see this transformation happen,
in all its gory glory.
In this rendition of the "Mortal Kombat" story,
it is Sub-Zero who brutally freezes and dismembers
Jax.
He gets his shiny synthetic limbs just in
time to kick plenty of Outworld butt and absolutely
destroy Reiko with his iconic "head clap"
fatality.
A warrior monk and champion of Earthrealm,
Liu Kang usually acts as the protagonist of
the "Mortal Kombat" game series.
This was directly translated to film in the
original 1995 "Mortal Kombat" movie.
The 2021 film, in contrast, introduces Cole
Young as the new main character, pushing Liu
Kang into a mentor role.
This is a serious departure from the much
larger role Liu Kang typically plays in "Mortal
Kombat" stories, which is made even more dramatic
by the fact that this "chosen one" takes a
backseat to many other major players in the
film.
Liu Kang's design in the 2021 movie is inspired
by his look in the early "Mortal Kombat" games,
as is the case with many of the film's other
fighters.
Noticeably absent from his cinematic arsenal
are the nunchaku he uses as a weapon in the
PlayStation 2 trilogy of 3D "Mortal Kombat"
games.
Those nunchaku were recently brought back
as Kang's primary weapon in 2019's "Mortal
Kombat 11."
Anyone who has only checked out that game
will find Liu Kang's silver screen fighting
style to be quite different from what they've
come to expect.
Slicing through his opponents with his unforgettable
wide-brimmed hat, Shaolin monk Kung Lao does
a whole lot of killing and not much talking
in 2021's "Mortal Kombat".
That's far from a complaint: We're all here
for the action, after all.
The new movie thankfully ticks most of the
boxes when it comes to this fan-favorite character.
Of course, his iconic hat, famously inspired
by alpha-henchman Oddjob's topper in 1964's
"Goldfinger," is a bloody tour-de-force, but
Kung Lao also does plenty of teleporting throughout
the movie's runtime.
Mentioned too is his lineage: He is a descendant
of the Great Kung Lao, legendary champion
of Earthrealm.
The 2021 film also adds another new wrinkle
to the mythology of "Mortal Kombat:" Here,
Liu Kang and Kung Lao are cousins.
Antagonist Shang Tsung doesn't take up much
screen time at all in the 2021 film, despite
the fact that he's Liu Kang's rival and the
main villain of the first "Mortal Kombat"
game.
In this movie, the rivalry between Shang Tsung
and Liu Kang isn't emphasized, though there
is some groundwork laid for it in a potential
future movie.
Absent too is any mention of Tsung's origin
as a Chinese human born in Earthrealm, who
was given his powers over dark sorcery by
Outworld emperor Shao Kahn.
That's not where the differences end, either.
Aesthetically, the Shang Tsung we see in the
movie doesn't resemble any of the Shang Tsungs
we've seen in the "Mortal Kombat" games.
Shang Tsung of the games is said to have been
based on Lo Pan, the villain of John Carpenter's
beloved film, "Big Trouble in Little China."
In the 2021 "Mortal Kombat" film, however,
Shang Tsung is decked out in heavy armor that
does not remotely resemble the light robes
he started off wearing in the games.
The only characteristics the "Mortal Kombat"
movie nails regarding Shang Tsung are his
shapeshifting abilities and his insatiable
thirst for human souls.
"Your soul is mine!"
Raiden doesn't get a whole lot of time in
the ring in the new Mortal Kombat movie, unless
you count the end, where he lighting-shocks
Shang Tsung back to Outworld.
Referred to by Liu Kang and Kung Lao only
as Lord Raiden, the god of thunder ends up
in a similar place as Shang Tsung does in
this film, taking a bit of a backseat to the
action.
Raiden is the leader and the eldest of the
Earthrealm protectors in the film.
When it comes to the games, however, he's
a lot more important: Raiden is one of the
few characters who makes an appearance in
every "Mortal Kombat" game, and he's playable
in all of them, except "Mortal Kombat 3.
While this god only has a small role in the
film, his silver screen design definitely
resembles the Raiden we see in most "Mortal
Kombat" games.
He's got his defining straw hat and his unmistakable
robe ensemble — really, it's all but identical
to what he sports in recent "Mortal Kombat"
games.
It would have been nice to see him flash his
moves while wearing these classic duds, but
you can't have everything you want ... even
when you're a thunder god.
A four-armed Shokan from Outworld, Goro is
one of the most instantly recognizable "Mortal
Kombat" characters ever designed.
In the 1995 movie, Goro is portrayed by actor
Tom Woodruff, wearing a mind-bogglingly complex
costume, with actors Kevin Michael Richardson
and Frank Welker providing Goro's speaking
voice and vocal effects, respectively.
The suit weighed roughly 125 pounds, and was
operated through a complicated combination
of puppetry, animatronics, and Woodruff's
own physicality.
Though 1995's Goro looks dated to modern eyes,
it's hard not to be impressed by the sheer
volume of practical effects work that went
into creating him.
The 2021 reboot, in contrast, takes the opposite
approach, going full-on CGI.
This new, digitally smooth Goro gets an introduction
and a short fight scene that sees him go up
against Cole.
Not much is explained about Goro in "Mortal
Kombat," and as a result, plenty of fun backstory
is omitted.
In the game series' lore, Goro is the one
who killed the Great Kung Lao, ancestor to
the hat-throwing Kung Lao of the main timeline.
This makes Goro a legendary warrior, but such
prestige doesn't come across at all in the
2021 film — instead, he feels like a henchman.
Also noticeably absent to anyone who mains
Goro in the game series are the green fireballs
he is known to shoot from his arm and mouth.
The single deepest cut the 2021 "Mortal Kombat"
movie makes in terms of characters has got
to be Nitara, the vampire from "Mortal Kombat:
Deadly Alliance."
Introduced in the fifth main game of the series,
only ever appearing again as a playable character
in "Mortal Kombat: Armageddon," Nitara was
an inspired choice to include in the movie.
Yet the Nitara of the silver screen is not
exactly the Nitara of the games.
Most notably, the new movie makes a few modernizing
edits to her aesthetic.
For starters, her outfit is a lot less revealing.
Secondly, her red bandana, which doubles as
an eye-patch for her left eye, is nowhere
to be found.
Aside from her bat-like wings, Nitara's signature
look rests upon the bandana and the charm
she wears around her neck, which allows her
to warp between realms.
Both of these defining accessories are completely
missing from the film.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.